Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. US-only exclusions apply.
现在通过家居建材市场（Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销活动，你的夏天就此开启。是时候用次世代燃气烤炉（这款四火眼燃气烤炉特价仅售199美元）来开启夏日烧烤派对了。还可以入手仅售49美元的汉普顿湾西格罗夫七件套户外餐桌椅，尽享一整季的户外欢聚。今年阵亡将士纪念日，家居建材市场承诺为您提供超低价格。售完即止，价格有效期至5月14日或5月27日。仅限美国本土，受相关条款约束。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Picking up a new skill as an adult can seem daunting. Whether it's learning to play the guitar, attempting to retile your bathroom, or learning a new language, you may feel like you just don't master new skills as fast as you did when you were a kid. And it can be hard to overcome the voice in your head
详情请参见 Home Depot.com/pricematch。作为成年人，学习一项新技能可能会让人望而生畏。无论是学弹吉他、尝试重新铺设浴室瓷砖，还是学习一门新语言，你可能都会觉得自己掌握新技能的速度不如小时候那么快。而且，你可能很难战胜内心的那个声音：
saying that you can't teach an old dog new tricks. But some psychologist's research suggests that continuing to learn new things throughout adulthood may be key to keeping your cognitive skills sharp as you age, and that in fact, middle-aged and older adults may be just as good at learning as younger people. So why does it seem so much harder to learn as we get older?
那就是“老狗学不会新把戏”。但一些心理学家的研究表明，在成年后持续学习新事物，可能是你在日渐年老时保持敏锐认知能力的关键。事实上，中年和老年人学习新事物的能力可能并不比年轻人逊色。那么，为什么随着年龄的增长，我们学东西会显得这么难呢？
What lessons can adults take from how children learn that can improve their own learning? Are all types of learning equally good for your brain health? Doesn't matter whether you do crossword puzzles, learn home improvement skills, or audit college courses. And if you want to learn something new, what's the best way to get started and persevere? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
成年人可以从儿童的学习方式中吸取哪些教训来提高自己的学习能力？所有类型的学习对你的大脑健康都一样有益吗？无论是做纵横填字游戏、学习家装技能，还是旁听大学课程，这重要吗？如果你想学点新东西，开始并坚持下去的最佳方法是什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Rachel Wu, an associate professor of psychology at the University of California Riverside, where she runs the cognitive agility across the lifespan lab. Her research focuses on understanding cognitive development and decline across the human lifespan from infancy to older adulthood in order to help learners maximize their learning potential at any age. She's authored dozens of academic studies, and her research has been covered by NPR, NBC News, and other media outlets. She's also a lifelong learner, having taken a painting, singing, and other new pursuits in adulthood. Dr. Wu, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. It's great to be here. Let's start with the broad question I just asked in the introduction. Why does it seem so much harder to learn new skills as we get older? It's difficult because we have so many other things we need to do. We have to pay bills. We have full-time jobs. We have a lot of things that can get in the way. And on top of that, we also have to take care of children maybe and do other things. And society and,
我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是加州大学河滨分校心理学副教授雷切尔·吴（Rachel Wu）博士，她在该校主持“跨生命周期认知敏捷性实验室”。她的研究重点是了解从婴儿期到老龄期的整个人类生命周期的认知发展与衰退，以帮助学习者在任何年龄都能最大限度地发挥学习潜力。她撰写了数十项学术研究，其研究成果已被美国全国公共广播电台（NPR）、全国广播公司新闻网（NBC News）等媒体报道。她本人也是一名终身学习者，在成年后涉足了绘画、歌唱和其他新领域。吴博士，非常感谢您今天能来到节目中。非常感谢邀请我，很高兴能来到这里。让我们从我刚才在介绍中提出的那个宏观问题开始：为什么随着年龄的增长，学习新技能似乎变得如此困难？这很困难，因为我们有太多其他事情需要做。我们要付账单。我们有全职工作。有很多事情会挡我们的路。除此之外，我们可能还要照顾孩子以及做其他事情。而且社会，
And we ourselves also don't let us, don't let ourselves learn as well. So we might say, oh, you know, I'll give myself 10 minutes to learn this. And if I don't learn it, I can't ever learn it. And so we give ourselves unrealistic goals, I think, to learn something. So if you think about learning a language, for example, we give babies at least a year to come up with their first word. And we give ourselves as adults maybe 10 minutes to learn our first word in a new language. And so it's just, it's a completely different approach that we take when we think about learning as adults. So what lessons can adults take from how children learn? And what's the difference between how kids learn and how adults learn other than they have a lot of time to learn?
我们自己也不允许、不让自己好好学习。所以我们可能会说：“哦，你知道的，我给自己10分钟来学这个，如果学不会，那我这辈子都学不会了。”因此，我认为我们在学习某样东西时，给自己设定了不切实际的目标。比如，如果你考虑学习一门语言，我们给婴儿至少一年的时间来学会他们的第一个词；而我们作为成年人，可能只给自己10分钟来学习一门新语言中的第一个词。因此，当我们把学习看作成年人时，我们采取的方法完全不同。那么，成年人可以从儿童的学习方式中吸取哪些教训？除了有大量时间学习之外，儿童的学习方式与成年人的学习方式有什么区别？
Right. So there's several things. One is children don't typically say, this is not relevant to me. I'm not going to learn it. Right. So they typically when they see something, they are curious. They just want to learn. whatever comes their way. And so as adults, we can also try to have more of that kind of attitude as well. So don't dismiss things as irrelevant and just take in what you can. So I call this input-driven learning. And then also children have a lot of help. So they have what I called individualized scaffolding. So they have parents, teachers, caregivers, anybody around neighbors even who want to help them learn something. And they're, they're all. always kind of at the ready to help them learn anything they need to learn. So as adults, though, it's really hard to find somebody to teach you how to learn, teach you something, right?
没错。所以有几点不同。首先，孩子们通常不会说：“这对我没用，我不学。”没错。所以他们通常在看到某些东西时会感到好奇。他们只是想学习迎面而来的任何东西。因此，作为成年人，我们也可以努力培养这种态度。不要把事情贬低为“不相关”，而是尽可能地去吸收。我把这称为“输入驱动学习”。其次，孩子们有大量的帮助。他们拥有我所谓的“个性化鹰架支持”。他们有父母、老师、照顾者，甚至周围的邻居，任何想帮他们学东西的人。他们随时准备着，帮助孩子们学习他们需要学的任何东西。然而，作为成年人，要找到一个教你如何学习、教你某样东西的人是非常困难的，对吧？
So if you want to learn, let's go back to the language example, if you want to learn another language, you have to pay somebody or maybe try to even, you know, if you're trying to learn how to use a new online banking platform, it's really difficult to find somebody to teach you how to do something. So that's the second thing. And we also have a very fixed mindset as adults. So if we don't know how to do something, it may be impossible for us to do, you know, to ever learn it, you know, ever. And so whereas kids, they don't often have this mindset when they're really young. And in fact, people around them don't put this mindset on them. They encourage them to learn. So if babies learning how to walk, we don't say,
所以如果你想学，让我们回到语言的例子，如果你想学另一门语言，你得付钱给别人，或者甚至尝试去（如果你正试图学习如何使用新的网上银行平台，要找人教你如何做一件事是非常困难的）。这是第二点。而且作为成年人，我们的思维非常僵化。如果我们不知道怎么做一件事，那我们可能永远也学不会了，对吧？而孩子们在很小的时候往往没有这种心态。事实上，他们周围的人也不会把这种心态强加给他们，而是鼓励他们学习。所以如果婴儿在学走路，我们不会对婴儿说：
to babies, oh, I don't think you're going to ever walk. So I'm just not going to bother teaching. It's not something that crosses our minds as parents and caregivers, right? So that's the third thing. And the fourth thing is there's a very forgiving environment. So if mistakes are made, kids are not thought of as senile or something, right? And these kinds of like environments that allow mistakes to happen and you're not defining yourselves based on what you know and things like that. And then also it's a very serious commitment that kids have when they're learning. So when they're in school and they're learning subjects and things, they're sticking to things for years, at least for months, right?
“哦，我觉得你永远都不会走路了，所以我甚至懒得去教你。”作为父母和照顾者，这根本不会闪过我们的脑海，对吧？这是第三点。第四点是，存在一个非常宽容的环境。如果犯了错，孩子们不会被认为老糊涂了什么的，对吧？这种允许犯错、并且你不会根据自己已知的东西来定义自己的环境……此外，孩子们在学习时有一种非常严肃的承诺。因此，当他们在学校学习科目和各种知识时，他们会坚持数年，至少是数月，对吧？
Whereas adults, if they try to learn something, it could be just for minutes or for, you know, at most a few weeks. And then finally, kids learn a lot of things simultaneously. So as adults, we might be learning things here and there once in a while and maybe sequentially or something. But the amount of learning that happens with kids is so much more. So they can define themselves as learners as opposed to adults who have a particular job and then learn on the side or something like that. Yeah. And does this encompass the...
而成年人如果尝试学点什么，可能只持续几分钟，或者最多几周。最后，孩子们同时学习很多东西。而作为成年人，我们可能只是偶尔在这里或那里学点东西，也许是按顺序来的什么的。但是孩子们所经历的学习量要大得多。所以他们可以将自己定义为“学习者”，而成年人则有特定的工作，然后在业余时间学习什么的。是的。这是否包含了……
definitions that you've come up with where the kids practice broad learning and adults mostly do specialized learning. That's what we're talking about, right? That's right. Yeah. And the idea is that you get paid to basically be productive in society, right? And so it's very, it's very hard to find a job that will pay you to kind of explore and engage in broad learning the way that kids do. And that's why we don't pay kids to be in school because they're not very productive. And so, so you get to a point in, a certain point in your life. And, and you're told, okay, you have to be productive now. You have to start making money. And so the way that works is, well, you can then have more specialized training. If, you know, if the job even allows extra training. Sometimes you're just hired, a lot of times
你提出的定义，即孩子们进行广泛的学习，而成年人主要进行专门的学习？这就是我们所讨论的，对吧？没错。是的。这个想法是，你获得报酬是为了在社会中基本上发挥生产力，对吧？因此，很难找到一份工作，会付钱让你像孩子们那样去探索和参与广泛的学习。这就是为什么我们不付钱让孩子们去上学，因为他们没有很高的生产力。所以，在你人生的某个阶段，在某个特定点，有人会告诉你：“好了，你现在必须具有生产力了。你必须开始赚钱了。”因此，这种运作方式就是：你可以进行更多的专业化培训。（如果工作甚至允许额外的培训的话。）有时候你被雇用，很多时候
you're just hired based on what you already know. Now, you did a study recently. were you asked older adults to learn a lot of new things at once, basically to take on the equivalent of a college course load. Can you talk about what you did and what you found and how did that intensive learning experience affect the older adults in the study? We brought in people that were 58 to about 86 years of age, and we asked them to take three courses over one quarter, so like a 10-week, 12-week session. And, um, and, um, and, um, and, um, and, um, and, um, and, um, and, and, we asked them, so this is essentially like an undergraduate, you know, quarter. And the classes that they had to take were like Spanish, photography, drawing, music composition,
你被雇用仅仅是因为你已经掌握的知识。现在，你最近做了一项研究。你让老年人一次学习很多新东西，基本上相当于承担大学课程的学业负担。你能谈谈你做了什么、发现了什么，以及这种高强度的学习经历如何影响了研究中的老年人吗？我们找来了年龄在58岁到86岁左右的人，我们要求他们在三个月（比如一个10周到12周的学期）内修读三门课程。而且，我们要求他们……所以这基本上就像是一个本科生的学期。他们必须上的课程包括西班牙语、摄影、绘画、音乐创作，
things like that. And they had to take three of the classes that we assigned to them. And we assigned them based on how little they knew about the classes. And then we said, if you have the, if you want to, you have the option to take up to the five classes that we were offering. And so some of the people wanted to take, you know, the additional two classes because they, let's say they were really interested in drawing, but then we didn't assign them to drawing because they had some drawing experience or something, right? So then they could still sit in the drawing class if they took the other classes. So, yeah, so after three months of taking these classes, they increased their cognitive abilities to levels that were initially similar to other older adults that didn't take the classes. to more like middle-aged adults who were taking the test for the first time. And so this was like a 30-year difference in terms of age.
诸如此类。他们必须修读我们指定给他们的三门课程。我们根据他们对这些课程的了解程度来指派课程。然后我们说：“如果你愿意，你有权选修我们开设的多达五门课程。”因此，有些人想选修额外的两门课程，因为比如说，他们对绘画非常感兴趣，但我们最初没有把绘画分配给他们，因为他们有一些绘画经验什么的，对吧？所以如果他们上了其他课，他们仍然可以去旁听绘画课。所以，是的，在上了三个月这些课之后，他们的认知能力提高到了最初与没有上过课的其他老年人相似的水平，
And then what was really astounding was after one year, after the end of the intervention, after the end of the classes, they ended up increasing their cognitive abilities, continuing to increase their cognitive abilities all the way up to levels that were similar to undergraduates, so like 20-year-olds, 50 years younger. who took the test for the first time. Yeah, that's pretty amazing. So how can people put findings like this into practice in the real world? I mean, what can you do if you don't have access to college classes or the time to take them?
更类似于第一次参加测试的中年人。就年龄而言，这相当于有30年的差距。然后真正令人震惊的是，在一年后，也就是干预结束后、课程结束一年后，他们的认知能力最终得到了提升，并且继续提升，一直提升到与本科生（也就是20多岁、比他们年轻50岁）第一次参加测试时相似的水平。是的，这相当惊人。那么，人们如何在现实生活中将这样的发现付诸实践？我的意思是，如果你无法接触到大学课程，也没有时间去上这些课，你能做些什么？
So if you don't have the time to take classes or time to learn a lot of new things, I can tell you that we may actually be quite efficient at learning as adults compared to children. So it might take us only 10 minutes to figure something out that would take a kid maybe five hours to figure out on their own. And so learning might not take as long as you think. And so if you have a full-time job, you can try to fit things in on the weekends. And maybe, you know, if you're trying to learn piano, I was learning piano while having a full-time job. I could practice maybe 10 minutes a day and then just cram everything I needed to practice that day into those 10 minutes and then have a one hour lesson once a week. And so it might not have to take as long as you think. If you don't have access,
因此，如果你没有时间去上课，或者没有时间学习很多新东西，我可以告诉你，与儿童相比，作为成年人，我们在学习方面实际上可能非常高效。弄明白一件可能需要小孩子自己花五个小时才能搞懂的事情，我们成年人可能只需要10分钟。所以学习可能不需要你想象的那么长时间。因此，如果你有一份全职工作，你可以试着在周末抽出时间。也许，如果你正试图学钢琴——我在拥有一份全职工作的同时也在学钢琴——我每天可以练习大约10分钟，然后把我那天需要练习的所有内容塞进那10分钟里，然后每周去上一小时的课。所以它可能不需要你想象的那么长时间。如果你无法接触到
to, you know, community colleges or classes that you could take. There are also classes online and other things that might be more accessible. There are more and more opportunities, especially low-cost or free opportunities, that are kind of popping up because of the pandemic that are available nationwide. We've all heard that at least some aspects of our cognitive abilities decline and our memory it gets worse as we age. What does the research say about this? How do cognition and memory change for most people as they get older and how do those finding square with the work you're doing on learning at any age? So there are a lot of studies that do show that as we get older, especially from
诸如社区学院或你可以上的课程，网上也有其他可能更容易获取的课程。由于大流行病，全国各地正在涌现出越来越多的机会，特别是低成本或免费的机会。我们都听说过，随着年龄的增长，我们的认知能力至少在某些方面会有所下降，记忆力也会变差。研究对此是怎么说的？对于大多数人来说，随着年龄的增长，认知和记忆是如何变化的？这些发现与你正在进行的“任何年龄都能学习”的工作是如何吻合的？所以有很多研究确实表明，随着我们年龄的增长，特别是从
midlife on, we do see declines in our cognitive abilities, especially attention and memory. But my research is trying to question, well, how much of that is under our control and how much of that is kind of predestined biological issues that are more out of our control. And so what we've been finding is that there actually can be quite a bit of movement in terms of your cognitive abilities if you're learning a lot of new skills. And so what if a lot of the decline that we see is premature or self-imposed in a way that we can increase cognitive abilities over time. So it's kind of a self-fulfilling prophecy that if you believe you can't learn, if you believe you're losing your memory, you will.
中年开始，我们的认知能力确实会出现下降，尤其是注意力和记忆力。但我的研究试图探讨的问题是：其中有多少是在我们控制之下的？又有多少是某种预定的、更多超出我们控制的生物学问题？因此，我们发现的是，如果你在学习很多新技能，你的认知能力实际上可以有相当大的提升空间。那么，如果我们看到的很多衰退其实是过早的或自己强加的呢？通过学习，我们随着时间的推移是可以提高认知能力的。所以这有点像是一个自我实现的预言：如果你相信自己学不会，如果你相信自己在失去记忆，你就会失去记忆。
Right. And what I typically tell people is, if you think about it, children who, if you pull children out of school and you give them the life of watching TV all day, not learning a lot of new things, they also would be declining too. Right. So it's not so much an age issue. It's a lifespan. issue for me. And so I ask people like, you know, people ask me, well, what will, what should I do? What, you know, how should I live my life? I don't know. But, but what I typically ask them is if you have, you know, grandchildren or you see children around, if you're happy with them living the kind of life that you live, then continue that way, right? So if they're, if you're learning a lot of new skills
没错。我通常对人们说的是：如果你仔细想想，那些如果把孩子们拉出学校，让他们过着整天看电视、不学很多新东西的生活，他们的认知能力也会下降的，对吧？所以对我来说，这与其说是一个年龄问题，不如说是一个生命周期问题。所以我问人们：人们问我，“那我该怎么办？我该怎么生活？”我不知道。但我通常问他们的是：如果你有孙辈，或者你看到周围有孩子，如果你对他们过着你现在这样的生活感到满意，那就继续这样下去吧，对吧？所以，如果你在学习很多新技能，
and they're learning a lot of new skills, then that's great. But if you think that, Doing crossword puzzles is enough, you know, to kind of maintain your cognitive abilities. And that is the life that you think children should live too. Then that's, there's some disconnect there, right? So children don't come out of school, like get pulled out of school just to learn how to do crossword puzzles. And then we expect their cognitive abilities to be maintained, you know? Yeah. And also the other thing is maintenance should not be the goal.
他们也在学习很多新技能，那很好。但如果你认为，做做纵横填字游戏就足以维持你的认知能力，并且你认为这也是孩子们应该过的生活，那么这就有些脱节了，对吧？孩子们不会刚从学校出来，或者被拉出学校，仅仅是为了学习如何做纵横填字游戏，然后我们就指望他们的认知能力能保持下去，对吧？是的。还有一件事是：维持不应该是最终目标。
So when you keep a kid in first grade, when they should actually be increasing and advancing to second grade, third grade, fourth grade. Maintenance is actually the last resort that we typically have with children, right? So we shouldn't think about maintenance as something that is the end goal in adulthood. We can, you know, bring ourselves to new levels, to experience new things to, yeah, to get to where we eventually want to be. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save?
当你把一个孩子留在一年级，而他们本该升级并进入二年级、三年级、四年级时……“维持现状”实际上是我们对儿童通常采取的最后手段，对吧？所以我们不应该把“维持”当作成年期追求的最终目标。我们可以把自己带到新的水平，去体验新事物，从而达到我们最终想要达到的地方。你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步路，可我们到现在还没找到台阶呢。我们省了多少钱？
Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected.
够了。够迷路的了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的房间。欢迎来到您的海景房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期待的住宿体验。
When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. You mentioned crossword puzzles a minute ago, and I don't want to malign crossword puzzles. I'm sure a lot of our listeners love them. And I do the spelling B in the New York Times every day. But does that count as learning and does it have any impact on cognition and learning? Or is it just kind of a fun thing to do?
当您想要省钱而不是意外惊喜时。您住在哪里至关重要。希尔顿伴您好梦常在。你刚才提到纵横填字游戏，我可不是想诋毁纵横填字游戏。我确信我们的很多听众都很喜欢它们。而且我每天也玩《纽约时报》的拼字游戏（Spelling Bee）。但这算不算学习？它对认知和学习有什么影响吗？还是说它只是一种好玩的事情？
Well, so it depends on how good you are at it. If you're terrible at it, if you're very good at it, chances are you probably plateaued to a point where, you know, there's probably some level of challenge, especially the New York Times. one, right? But it's not going to be as challenging as learning a new skill that you have zero idea how to do. So if you, do you know how to play the trumpet, for example? I don't. Okay. So if you, learning how to play the trumpet versus the spelling, or the crossword puzzle, right? The level of challenge is just unparalleled, right? So it's just completely different in terms of how you're engaging different systems in your brain. So the more, the more, you're doing things that you know how to do, the more you're engaging kind of habit systems
嗯，这取决于你玩得有多好。如果你在这方面很糟糕……如果你在这方面非常擅长，你很可能已经达到了一个瓶颈期，在这个瓶颈期里，可能存在一定程度的挑战，尤其是《纽约时报》的那种，对吧？但它的挑战性不会像学习一项你完全一无所知的新技能那样高。所以，比如说你知道怎么吹小号吗？我不会。好吧。所以，学习吹小号与拼字游戏或纵横填字游戏相比，对吧？挑战的级别简直无法比拟，对吧？所以在调动大脑中不同系统方面，它们是完全不同的。所以，你越是
and the less you're engaging systems that overall decline with age. So then as an adult, if I'm watching YouTube videos to figure out how to fix a toilet for the first time or maybe switching from an Android to an iPhone, that I'm really learning something because it's new and different. Right. And, you know, the other thing I want to emphasize here is that at some point, everybody probably has to be learning something new to stay independent. Or you pay somebody to do something for you and then you become dependent on that person. And so what is actually more important than the cognitive abilities that we're talking about here is the ability to stay independent over time. And so if you're learning new things, a lot of new things, you have the confidence also then to tackle whatever new things you have to be learning to stay independent.
在做那些你本来就知道怎么做的事情，你就越是在调动习惯系统，而调动那些随年龄增长而整体衰退的系统的程度就越低。那么作为一个成年人，如果我正在看 YouTube 视频来摸索如何第一次修理马桶，或者可能从安卓手机换成苹果手机，那我真的是在学新东西，因为它是崭新而不同的。没错。而且，我想在这里强调的另一件事是：在某个时候，每个人可能都必须学习一些新东西来保持独立性。否则，你就要付钱请别人为你做某事，然后你就会变得依赖那个人。因此，比我们在这里谈论的认知能力更重要的是随着时间推移保持独立的能力。所以，如果你在学新东西，学很多新东西，你也会有信心去应对为了保持独立而必须学习的任何新事物。
And so, for example, from the study that we conducted, we had participants during the pandemic say to us, I learned how to fix my toilet, I learned how to do my own nails because they had gone through this huge learning study with us. They learned three new things at the same time. And so they were not afraid to learn anything new that came their way because of the pandemic. So I think that's a really important thing to emphasize, because especially with new technology and new things. things that might be more daunting for older learners. People think, I can't do it. It's impossible to learn or too old to learn or something. And as soon as you start learning, the second, the fourth, the fifth thing you learn is going to be much easier than the very first thing you learn in a long time. What's the difference between memorizing and learning? Does memorizing have the same
因此，举个例子，在我们开展的研究中，在大流行期间，有参与者对我们说：“我学会了怎么修马桶，我学会了怎么自己做美甲”，因为他们和我们一起经历了这项庞大的学习研究。他们同时学习了三样新东西。因此，面对大流行带来的任何新事物，他们不再害怕去学习。所以我认为这是一个非常需要强调的重要点，因为特别是对于新技术和可能让老年学习者望而生畏的新事物。人们会想：“我做不到。这根本学不会，我太老了学不会”什么的。而一旦你开始学习，你学的第二样、第四样、第五样东西，就会比你长久以来学的第一样东西容易得多。死记硬背和学习有什么区别？死记硬背有和学习一样的好处吗？
benefits as learning? Memorizing, it depends on what you're memorizing. So if you're memorizing new things for the thing that you're, for like, I'm talking more about like learning new skills. And so they're kind of procedural and like manual things maybe that you're doing, but also kind of knowledge, like content knowledge as well. And so if you're memorizing and not actually putting things to use, then it's not going to be as helpful probably for your everyday life. So memorizing a phone number, for example,
死记硬背，这取决于你在背什么。如果你在为……比如说，我更多的是在谈论学习新技能。所以它们可能是程序性的和手动的东西，但也包括知识，比如内容知识。因此，如果你只是死记硬背，却没有真正把东西付诸实践，那么它对你的日常生活可能就不会那么有帮助。所以，背诵一个电话号码，对吧，
sure, but then if you're not calling that person, probably not that useful. And so we have the same issue with kids. We're trying to switch over from, you know, kind of wrote learning, like more memories, like things that were more about memorizing facts, you know, with kids to now more about critical thinking, right, in education. So I think that that is also really important link that is that we can draw across the lifespan too. How important is feedback to learning and how do you get feedback when you're trying to learn new things on your own? It's very, very important.
当然可以，但如果你根本不给那个人打电话，那可能就没多大用处。我们在对待孩子时也遇到了同样的问题。在教育中，我们正试图从死记硬背（比如更多关于记忆的事实，教孩子们死记硬背事实）转变为更多地关注批判性思维，对吧？所以我认为这也是我们可以在整个人类生命周期中建立的一个非常重要的联系。反馈对学习有多重要？当你尝试自学新东西时，你是如何获得反馈的？非常非常重要。
It's one of the critical pieces of learning because it will tell you how to improve in whatever skill you're trying to learn. And so one thing that is hard about feedback is that it tells you where you've made mistakes. And so as an older learner, you might think, well, I'm making a ton of mistakes and I can't learn, you know, so that all of these kinds of thoughts might occur while you're learning and getting feedback. So getting feedback is an excellent tool to help you improve your learning. So I hope that all learners don't forget that, you know, feedback is very important. And to get feedback, when you're learning on your own, that's one of the key problems with adult learning.
它是学习的关键部分之一，因为它会告诉你如何在你想学的技能上进行改进。关于反馈，有一件困难的事是它会告诉你你在哪里犯了错。因此，作为年长的学习者，你可能会想：“嗯，我犯了一大堆错误，我学不会，对吧？”所以在学习和接受反馈的过程中，所有这些想法都可能会浮现。因此，获取反馈是帮助你提高学习成果的绝佳工具。所以我希望所有的学习者都不要忘记这一点：反馈非常重要。而要获得反馈，当你自学时，这是成人学习的关键问题之一。
children get feedback all the time when they're learning because they're typically learning with other people, even peers, right, in classrooms. And so adults when they're learning, if we're learning on our own, it's very difficult to get feedback. So if you're learning from like a YouTube video, there isn't going to be a lot of feedback because it's a one way system. And so that's why I would encourage people to be in a setting with at least, you know, some peers and a knowledgeable teacher or something like that to. help guide them. There are some skills that you can learn on your own that, you know, maybe if you're kind of observant enough, then you can give yourself feedback, but you're limited by your own skills in terms of how much feedback you can get for yourself. But if you have somebody else there, like my piano teacher would catch things that I would not even hear because she has the
孩子们在学习时随时都能得到反馈，因为他们通常和别人一起学习，甚至是在课堂上和同龄人一起学习，对吧。因此，当成年人在学习时，如果我们是自学，要获得反馈是非常困难的。所以如果你通过像 YouTube 视频这样的途径学习，就不会有很多反馈，因为这是一个单向系统。这就是为什么我鼓励人们置身于至少有一些同龄人和一个知识渊博的老师之类的环境中，来指导他们。有些技能你可以自学，如果你观察力足够敏锐，那么你可以给自己反馈，但你自己的技能水平限制了你能为自己获得多少反馈。但如果你有另一个人在场，比如我的钢琴老师会注意到一些我甚至听不到的问题，因为她拥有
expertise that I just don't have because I'm not at that level. What about just testing yourself, is that the same as feedback? Testing yourself is good, except that you're only as good as your current skill level is, right? So how do you get to the next level of what you're supposed to be? Like, how can you test yourself if you don't know what you're supposed to be testing yourself on sometimes, you know? And so we don't expect kids to test themselves when they're, you know, learning a new subject in school or something like that.
我所不具备的专业知识，而我没有达到那个水平。那么仅仅是自我测试呢？这和反馈是一样的吗？自我测试很好，但前提是你的水平只能达到你目前的技能水平，对吧？那么，你如何才能达到本该达到的下一个水平呢？有时候，如果你根本不知道自己应该测试什么，你又怎么能自我测试呢，对吧？所以我们不会期望孩子们在学校里学习新科目之类的时候去自我测试。
So some subjects you are able to do that with, but it's just very difficult to do that when it's something that it might be a skill that would take years to master, you know, like learning a new language. How important is failure in learning, especially for adults? Failure is really important, but it can also be kind of demoralizing. You can feel like I can't do this, depending on how big the failure is. I suppose. And so it's something that a really good teacher can help kind of contain. So if you have a really good teacher, they can maybe turn the failure into something to show you that there was some success, even if some things failed.
所以有些科目你可以做到这一点，但当它是一项可能需要数年才能掌握的技能时，比如学习一门新语言，这就很难做到。失败在学习中有多重要，特别是对成年人来说？失败非常重要，但它也可能会让人士气低落。根据失败的程度，你可能会觉得“我做不到”。我想是这样的。因此，一个真正优秀的老师可以帮助控制这种情绪。所以如果你有一个真正优秀的老师，他们也许能把失败变成某种东西，向你展示即使有些事情失败了，也还是取得了一些成功。
And to show you how little by little you're getting better over time, even if it feels like you're failing a lot. I also think that failure is more fond. final, then it actually is. So some people might say, oh, I failed at that thing. And then you quit. And I'm never going to return to it. Right.
并向你展示，尽管感觉自己好像经常失败，但你正在一点一点地随着时间的推移变得更好。我也认为，失败比它实际上的样子要更具有最终性。所以有些人可能会说：“哦，我在那件事上失败了。”然后你就放弃了，并且“我再也不会去碰它了。”
And then I quit. And so that's the role of a really good teacher because like if a kid says, oh, I failed at riding my bike for the first time, then somebody usually tells them, well, let's try again. And, you know, if you put your feet this way and you turn the wheels this way, then it might make it a little easier. And then the kid little by little then sees a bit more success. over time. You've put your research into practice in your own life through learning new skills, such as
然后我就放弃了。这就是一个真正优秀的老师的作用所在，因为如果一个孩子说：“哦，我第一次学骑自行车失败了”，通常会有人对他们说：“嗯，让我们再试一次。而且，如果你把脚这样放，把车把这样转，可能会容易一点。”然后孩子就会一点一点地看到更多的成功，随着时间的推移。你把你的研究付诸实践，通过学习新技能（比如
painting and singing, and you mentioned piano, and I know you were studying German. Which came first? Were you always this kind of a learner? And then you got into the research, or did you start the research and you said, I have to do this myself? I got into learning first, and then I saw the, I experienced the kinds of comments that. that adult learners typically get, like, you're too old to learn this.
绘画和唱歌，你还提到了钢琴，我知道你还在学德语）应用到了你自己的生活中。哪个先开始的？你一直都是这种类型的学习者吗？然后你才开始做研究的？还是你先开始做研究，然后说：“我必须亲自尝试一下？”我先开始学习，然后我看到了、体验到了成人学习者通常会得到的那些评论，比如：
So I first started with painting and drawing and sculpting, and people would say you have no artistic bone in your body. You can barely draw stick figures, you know, like, why are you wasting your time? Just finish up your PhD and get a job. Don't quit your day job kind of thing. And so, yeah, so it got me thinking, because I was studying babies at the time,
“你太老了，学不会这个。”我最初是从绘画、素描和雕塑开始的，人们会说：“你身上没有一点艺术细胞，你连火柴人几乎都画不出来，你知道吗？你为什么在浪费时间？赶紧完成你的博士学位，找份工作去吧。别辞掉你的正职工作。”诸如此类的话。所以，是的，这让我开始思考，因为我当时正在研究婴儿，
you don't hear these kinds of comments with babies at all. And so it got me thinking about, well, why do we limit what adults have to learn over time? And then I thought maybe it was a fluke that it was maybe I don't have an artistic bone in my body, whatever. So I stuck with it and then I got better. And then over time, people would say, oh, you're so talented. You had this artistic gene, this entire time that you uncovered. So they attributed all this time I spent at the easel, all the time I spent with my sculpting teachers to talent, to something that was innate. And so then really got me thinking, well, maybe there's something there that's kind of more of a mindset shift over time as we age.
你在婴儿身上根本听不到这种评论。这让我开始思考：为什么我们要限制成年人在随着时间推移必须学习的东西？然后我以为这可能只是个巧合，也许我身上真的没有艺术细胞什么的。但我坚持下去了，然后我变得更好了。再后来，人们会说：“哦，你太有才华了。你一直都有这种艺术基因，现在才被你发掘出来。”因此，他们把我在画架前花的所有时间、跟雕塑老师学习的所有时间，都归功于天赋，归功于某些与生俱来的东西。所以这真的让我开始思考：也许这其中有些东西更倾向于随着我们年龄增长而发生的心态转变。
And maybe that's preventing people from learning new things. And then it got me thinking, well, what kinds of benefits can you get from learning new things? we get older. Now, what are the issues that you're working on at the moment? What are some of the big questions that have yet to be answered in your area? So it's really interesting that you asked that because before the pandemic, we were asking, should older adults be learning new things to increase cognitive abilities, to increase their independence and things like that?
也许正是这一点阻碍了人们学习新事物。然后这让我思考：随着我们年龄的增长，从学习新事物中究竟能获得什么好处？现在，你目前正在进行哪些课题的研究？在你的领域里，有哪些重大问题还有待解答？这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为在大流行之前，我们一直在问：老年人应该学习新事物以提高认知能力、增强独立性等等吗？
And then during the pandemic, I realized that was actually the completely wrong question. the question is given that we have to be learning new things throughout our lifespan. What is the best way to encourage learning over time? And so it turns out people have different barriers to learning. So some have a lot of motivation and very few resources. Some have a lot of resources and very little motivation. Some people have a lot of motivation, a lot of motivation, a lot of resources, resources and not and relatively low cognitive abilities to be able to pick up what they want to
然后在大流行期间，我意识到这其实是一个完全错误的问题。问题在于，鉴于我们在整个生命周期中都必须学习新事物，随着时间的推移，鼓励学习的最佳方法是什么？事实证明，人们在学习上面临着不同的障碍。有些人有很多动力，但资源很少；有些人有很多资源，但动力很少；有些人有很强的动力，也有很多资源，
learn. And so I think identifying the individual differences and what the barriers are is really important. And so what we're doing now is targeting different groups that have different barriers to learning and then seeing if we can help lower those barriers to them get them to be able to learn new things that they want to learn. Well, Dr. Wu, I want to thank you for joining me. I think this has been very encouraging. Thank you for having me. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeck or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get podcasts.
但认知能力相对较低，无法掌握他们想要学习的东西。因此，我认为识别个体差异以及这些障碍是什么非常重要。所以我们现在正在做的是，针对那些面临不同学习障碍的不同群体，看看我们能否帮助降低这些障碍，使他们能够去学习他们想要学习的新事物。吴博士，非常感谢你今天能来。我认为这次访谈非常具有启发意义。谢谢你的邀请。你可以在我们的网站 www.combeck 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的平台上收听往期的《心理学谈话》。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以给我们发邮件：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·维纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪永（Chris Condyion）。谢谢收听。我是来自美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。